hey guys i'm ryan right so several
people sent this video to me daniel's
promposal
I guess he proposes out of problems when
you ask a girl the prom I don't know I
never been a problem really clever
it's overrated because I was
home-schooled
the only person I could take was my mom
and she didn't want to go with me I know
what the problems are in her kitchen she
was like no that's too far really hoping
that is that you know that's not
Gerardus he has a bigger nose in her
[Music]
condoms and everything ready to go yes
I'm sorry it's
[Music]
no I know you told me oh yeah but like
likewise horrible driver
[Music]
I'm being if you if you're just not
interested
[Music]
clawing up details
[Music]
[Music]
so he he already has video video
so
marry
ah
you
[Music]
- oh yeah oh she's like I wouldn't feel
so bad
we're not a going according to plan
[Music]
turn up the video I'm sorry don't kill
me I didn't want to see her I don't want
the video never fall in their eyes I did
fortunately obviously yeah she said yes
okay
Wow humiliating that must have been talk
that is one of the worst things when you
think oh this is gonna be something that
earns me so many points and then a
backfire so badly I feel so bad I mean
okay well first off she seems kind of
like a negative woman I mean early it
was about like 6:00 a.m. I'd be in a
crappy mood - I know but if you see
someone ask someone a prom like that
kind of like from the joyride movie
except instead of a serial killer
putting signs it's a prom asking that is
pretty romantic she probably got jealous
thinking that was for someone else which
is why she thought it was like crabby I
don't see the jealousy at all what are
you talking about when she saw all the
signs I know it's a crappy way to
someone a prom she'd probably said that
because she you know was jealous that
someone got asked to promise you didn't
yeah well it seemed very romantic but
when she start breaking down and crying
that was really sad because that level
of guilt that she felt like it sir it's
probably her first time being asked to
prom might be the only time you go and
you just like what after she had cried
or whatever she looks really happy like
hey I'm going to prom and he still
looked really hurt like I would be
really hurt he's probably embarrassed
yeah - but he posted it in this video
and viral so good for him he's made good
amount of money off of embarrassing
himself and his girlfriend well anyway
guys thanks for sending that to me that
was [ __ ] funny if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out salamander
Sally's channel it's such a channel and
it's a fun fun channel I don't know what
this is a repeat of things and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where if we get enough followers
we can get product placement hence now
I'm gonna do shoutouts no no we'll save
that sandwich for the next one next
video
Louie Rodriguez Orion so I'll say thanks
for the laughs
you bring your the youtuber I look
forward to seeing on my feed now keep it
up all right shut up Luis Rodriguez my
friend I want to thank you for all the
laughing you do at my jokes you're the
fan I look forward to seeing on my feet
now you keep it up my friend trying to
be positive to the shoutouts now
everyone keeps saying I'm a dick oh and
I thought was a sex joke no no he said
keep it up and I said keep it up back
but Luis Rodriguez I do believe that you
know I mean you got to keep it up you
know you got to work hard at it you know
sometimes you just got to keep pushing
just you know penetrate success and Luis
Rodriguez knows how hard it can be to
keep it up using but it yeah he has a
rekt I love this function that they do
there's certain medications you can take
but it unfortunately Luis does not know
how to keep it up so I have to keep it
up for both of us it is a lot of
pressure but when you keep plugging the
pressure is good